you know when i wear the jackets all of
a sudden
i'm wolverine you know and i i i love
that look i'm over here seducing myself
yo what's up gq this is masego and these
are my 10 essentials
first we have yankee candle i get it
there's probably like a soy candle i
should be using or something
environmentally amazing but these smell
great to me
i bring them everywhere on tour like i
don't have a lot of things that i get
upset about but if this is not near me
i need that i don't know if you've
noticed i have large nostrils the
internet is surely noticed
this helps that struggle
to breathe in so much pink sands i'm
only getting pink sands
i literally have a stock supply at my
house it smells like
okay you got the beach just pick any
beach and then there's a private beach
that somebody buy
that they really make a fuss if you step
on their property that's what it smells
like the
untouched promised land i had this
layover
in moscow for like 13 hours in the
airport so i just go in the candle shop
and i smell
everything and pink sands is the one
they got this in sprays
car fresheners oils i got all of it
it's in the kitchen it's in the bathroom
bedroom studio
guest room foyer i come home and the
candle's lit
i don't know who did it it's lit though
we have
phillips hue light based in amsterdam
this is the mood setter
who put me on to this i think it was
roswell roswell is one of my most techie
friends
i used to work at best buy too and so
did he and he was like yo man these hue
lights and i was like
uh this is stupid why would you want to
have colored lights now that i have
money i understand
like every single how like light bulb in
my home
are these seriously as a creative i love
certain colors because it keeps me in a
mood
i feel like purples and pinks make me
make a certain type of music
my roommate loves red for some reason so
he's currently in therapy to figure out
why
i have some friends that love blue some
love green but and as a host a lot i
love for people to feel comfortable
so i'm like you know what color do you
create with best and i just set the
house lights to that
i got it from my parents i got it from
my homies i just i think you need at
least
one you like no cards
whenever i'm traveling whenever like
people are bored whenever
we're trying to like make time go by i
like this game i love this game actually
we get to gamble with it when the band
we get to do truth to dare with it and i
love that it's just numbers and colors
like i go anywhere in the world
people understand how to play uno or i
can teach them real quick keith smith
spirits high
and i still can't shuffle i just think
it's a nice game to figure out how do
you take defeat
like you know are you a sore loser i
like to see like how are you
under pressure i actually have uno music
that i have a playlist of which it
really sounds like your own survivor i
don't think i'm competitive i just win a
lot
next we have bose headphones
i really should have just called this my
inhaler because if i don't listen to
music before
any human interaction i am a jerk so i
feel like i love that this is like
a form of meditation and therapy and
health
where i can just be in my own little
world play some of my playlists
and then i'm good i think they're just
made well like it has noise cancellation
that's really good
i like the wildest ones just because the
shorty talk to you you know
i don't like to talk unless it's about
like
a topic that i enjoy but the things we
want to talk with me about is like hey
so uh being tall like what's that like
so i like to avoid very uh
small talk as they call it this is the
small talk
avoider ipod this
is the shuffle i don't like to be on my
phone i feel like
all i really should use it for is
listening to music so i was like alright
forget the phone
i'm more of a letters guy it's cool
because you have to put things on here
you can't just search it up you can't be
spoiled
you appreciate what you took the time to
curate and i'm really big on playlists
that i receive from people
and then i make myself so i like to have
a couple different moves in here
and then i go find that ipod when i'm in
that mood i'm not burning battery
because i'm over here
emailing and instagramming it's just
literally for music only
i first got the one that 50 cent had in
his music video
he claims he's the one that made
everybody think is cool
i believed it enough to buy that one so
maybe he's right under appreciated item
forget the phones
get back to ipods sponsor me apple we
have
calvin klein all people ask what i
wear and i see the comments like he
probably smells like shea butter and
coconut
and kindness i probably disappointed
people with this i love
this particular smell of copper i really
have to search to find this one for
whatever reason and this was that same
13-hour layover in moscow i smelled
every single
column the musk the dry the this one's
sweet
this is the one that i most enjoyed it's
not real obnoxious like you're sitting
next to the man on the plane it's just
like we get it your time forward but
this is like a really like
who's what is that that gumption like
you you don't even know who did it but
it's like yo
you make good music this is expensive
and also it's hard to find
so i'm not going to just wake up like up
all right about to go eat some oatmeal
gotta smell like golden but
when it's time to show somebody who in
the room you put on that all that's a
commercial too come on
when i put this on and i'm around uh you
know
people with noses they appreciate the
scent
and see i put the cologne on it it's
attracting someone to walk in the room
no please
come in or not the power of the cologne
i'm trying to tell y'all for my next
item we have
courtesy of my cousin in jamaica
melatonin sleep science
nutra spray i struggle with sleep like
any other
entertainer or whatever i don't know
like this works i don't even know what
to tell you like
at the end of the day a couple sprays i
got my eight hours of sleep i'm happy my
skin doesn't go
crazy so now i have a stock supply of
these this is like a under the tongue
type of thing
orange flavor you really feel it like
right under your eyes
it's just like all right hey and it's
not forcing you it's not no z quilting
no shade is equal it
has some good years with them but it's
like no grogginess
it's a nice little flow and it's like
hey hey hey you want a dream i'm like i
would love to dream
thank you i'll go dream now water
i drink a gallon a day you should do it
too there was a guy named
said he walked into my studio with a
canister similar to this but smaller me
being
the modern-day emperor cusco i found a
better version of it
and this is this looks like me it's a
tall black
solid individual it's elegant it's
called mana
and it has this uh pokemon like symbol
on it like it's the water
pokemon so uh it makes me laugh a little
bit
keeps it cold for five days or your
money back i'm here to tell people
you're the reason why you're tired
there's your energy right there
get you some i mean you know i mean i'm
here to let them know they need some
mana
you know this sounds strong too this is
like what the juggernaut would walk
around with
and it's not compensating for anything
like this all of me looks like this
you know old b wouldn't have brought
this on tour but maybe the new me should
we have silk i don't wear silk every day
but i have some aspect of it involved in
my life
whether it's the bed sheets whether it's
a silk bonnet
silk do rag a silk shirt silver's nicer
everyone thinks i wear it so i'm like
all right
they keep giving me free silk things
it's just it's a thing i don't know i'm
kind of stuck with it
clothes make me become certain
characters and as a gemini i need a way
to filter through all these people
within me
the silk shirt just it really activates
a very elegant version of myself
you know you can't just wear silk
without the rings without the
drip as the kids say it makes you become
this like
this guy i think it's fun when i was
making my last album
uh the lady lady album it kind of felt
like
silk and it's kind of like a natural
graduation from hawaiian shirts because
i used to be at the thrift stores buying
up
all the hawaiian shirts for a quarter
and then you know when i got a little
more
mana i uh bought some silk shirts
and it just kind of went from there you
know because i i always loved the
the patterns and all the things that
came with hawaiian shirts but then it
got a little too vacation
a little too even steve in the movie so
we had to upgrade it
and then here i am today
well for my final item i have currency
with my face on it i like to call it
trap house cash it started when i was
traveling and i got in love with the way
that
everyone's currency looks versus
american currency
i have a friend named nancy and um she
designed
all the currencies in the world but with
my face on it but like in a very
tasteful creative way because like this
looks like a euro
even with the us currency i think this
is nice too and then the cool thing
about it is i ran it down at the end of
my shows and it doubles as a business
card
so it has my socials right here and it
also says uh in yams we trust
because um i like yams i feel like
they're underappreciated
so like we would just rain it down
stripper style people would end up
calling me
emailing me and we'd get a bunch of gigs
because of it so it was cool
over the years you know people have jot
you know i'm not going to call any names
out you know 50 cent
you know i'm saying snoop dogg but it's
cool you know i'm here to inspire
i have gotten in trouble in multiple
countries because
other people tried to pay with my money
and they blame me like i
called it i don't make dishonest people
they make themselves
yo lgq thanks for spending time with me
this is masego and these are my 10
essentials